welcome back to this special edition
of hannity before we go i want to tell
you about my new book
doesn't hurt to ask using the power of
questions to communicate connect and
persuade
it's not about what i believe it's about
helping you prove what you believe it's
out next week and it will help you make
your case and move others closer to your
way
of thinking thank you for joining us
tonight sean will be back on monday the
ingram angle is up next
have a great weekend
welcome to the ingram angle i'm raymond
arroyo sitting in
for laura ingram i have an amazing
lineup tonight that you will not want to
miss we're going to talk to a chicago
alderman who's not only his home but his
office
was ransacked violent script he is going
to come here and talk about
what is happening on the ground you have
a mayor and local prosecutors who are
failing to act
we're also going to talk with a college
student as well as
experts on covid and what's happening at
the university level and later take you
inside
that trump deal that that uae
uh israeli deal it's an amazing lineup
please stay with us
but first my thoughts on universities
and what's happening there
united we stand divided we snitch in
addition to the lockdowns and
uh the mask mandate presidential nominee
joe biden has
one big coveted plan
individual states like new york and
california already hiring and training
thousands of tracers
but we need to do more including hiring
at least one hundred thousand federally
funded workers to perform
contact tracing and other public health
tasks and they should begin to be
trained now
and they are being trained by the
thousands to track your whereabouts
and who you've been in contact with
using apps
and person-to-person interviews tracers
are essentially health snoops
they're recording all your interactions
now this
is a tracer trainer in houston
there's been plenty of people who have
broke down and cried
because they thought they were going to
lose their jobs
and they don't want to give any kind of
information that uh
that we don't already have in our hands
now liberal governors and mayors have
mostly waived off privacy concerns
they've not only embraced the tracing
regimen but they've taken enforcement of
their health orders
a step further hogan in maryland and
bashar
of kentucky set up hotlines to rat out
neighbors
those who are not in compliance with our
state orders
uh this is a call that can allow
government to know
to make sure that we know what you know
la mayor garcetti was even more explicit
you know the old expression about
snitches well in this case
snitches get rewards we want to thank
you
for turning folks in and making sure we
are all
safe turning folks in that snitch
mindset
has now hit universities across america
to return to campus
many college students are being required
to sign
contracts with their schools promising
to abide
by new covid requirements mask wearing
social distancing
eating alone in some cases routine
testing no overnight dorm parties
nothing violators face suspension
or expulsion but how do they enforce the
covet contracts on campus
enter the wellness ambassadors
tu public health ambassadors are
volunteer students faculty and staff
who will model and monitor physical
distancing practices the university is
encouraging
all of our you know students um to abide
by the covet guidelines and sometimes we
may have to
enforce some of these guidelines if
people do not abide by them we also have
our wellness support ambassadors
who will check for compliance at the
entrances of all of our buildings
and our classrooms the wellness support
ambassador will check your papers at the
library and before every class
that's right you pay 50 to 60 some cases
eighty thousand dollars a year
to have your kids basically enter what
is now a soviet style
people's republic of education where
their peers are encouraged
to spy on them and turn them over to
administrators
you might call it snitch you
if you think i'm exaggerating i'm not
now bear in mind most of these
universities require
all returning students to take covet
tests before they can even enter campus
columbia is recruiting student
ambassadors to help police the student
body
the university of miami is paying 10
bucks an hour
for their public health ambassadors and
they're not alone
a slew of colleges are training health
minders and losing them
on the student bodies at my alma mater
nyu students are instructed
to confront anyone not wearing a mask or
social distancing and quote if the
person persists in not complying
or responds confrontationally you should
not pursue the matter face-to-face
instead report
fellow student non-compliance
these universities are not playing
around
we need people to adopt healthful
behaviors immediately and
i can tell you we're going to pull out
all the stops from the research evidence
and also we're going to have a high
level of expectation that folks in the
community will respond
to um to our guidance the threshold will
be
very very low and we'll be holding
people accountable
the question which we will explore
shortly with experts as well as a texas
student
is this what effect do these university
covet student spy rings
have on community cohesiveness does it
undermine the academic
and personal freedom young people need
for growth
intellectually and socially and are our
institutions of higher education no
matter what they're calling these kids
health ambassadors forcing all students
to major in practical snitching